>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington D.C.
>> Marie Arana: Hi, Good
evening, ladies and gentlemen.
Great to have you
with us tonight.
Welcome to the Library
of Congress.
Welcome to the kickoff of La voz
latina, which is a series long
in the making, I guess
it was about a year ago,
Alicia and Giorda, we were
talking with the Kennedy Center
and managed this
wonderful collaboration
between the Library of
Congress and the Kennedy Center.
There Will be two more
programs tomorrow night.
I Will -- Sorry,
Saturday, all day long,
and I encourage you to go.
The first program at
eleven o'clock will be
with Natasha Trethewey,
the U.S. poet laureate,
and Jorge Ignacio Cortiñas,
who is a wonderful playwright,
Cuban playwright, and they
will present a program,
a really wonderful program on
the relationship and friendship
between two great poets,
Nicolás Guillén, of Cuba,
and Langston Hughes,
of the United States,
who were great friends
and wonderful poets,
and translated one another.
The other program
is at two o'clock,
and that would be a cavalcade
of great Latin American
and Latino American writers,
and you can see in your program
who they are, is a
magnificent lineup [inaudible]
which I encourage you to come
on Saturday, eleven o'clock
and two o'clock, and between
those programs, Rolando Estévez,
who you see here
tonight, the great,
wonderful master bookmaker
that we are very lucky to have
in the Library of Congress
tonight will be presenting more
of his books that are on their
way, right now, from Habana,
large scale material that
he has brought as well.
So, the display, if you've seen
it, is absolutely marvelous,
breathtaking work that he
has produced over the years,
and the display at the
Kennedy Center will be an
additional bonus.
So, I would encourage
you to go to that.
We are very, very indebted
to the extraordinary director
of the international programing
at the Kennedy Center,
Alicia Adams, and ger fantastic
dynamo colleague Giorda Almada.
We are very proud of
this collaboration
between the Library
and the Kennedy Center.
I think it may be
the - unprecedented,
a first collaboration of this
sort of scholarly material,
we think so, and so we hope
that it will be the first
of many other collaborations
in the future.
So, I want to bring on Alicia
to say a few words to you.
Alicia Adams, as I
say, is the director
of the International Program
in the Kennedy Center.
It is through her
that Washington audiences
have been treated to authors
from really all around
the world,
from China to Scandinavia,
to Africa, to all the Spanish
and Portuguese-speaking
nations, the Middle East,
India and many other fascinating
places whose art we might not
know but for her efforts
and those of her colleagues,
like Giorda, and the very
efficient Ginger Rogers,
thank you, Ginger.
If you were to keep track
of Alicia's productions,
you could virtually tour
the world and see artists
and art forms that you
hadn't imagined existed,
from the comfort of your
seat at the Kennedy Center.
So I'd like to ask
Alicia to come up
and say a few words,
if you would.
Alicia Adams.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Alicia Adams: Thank
you so much, Marie,
that's quite an introduction.
I don't know if I can live up
to that right now, but [risa].
I'd like to thank you
all for coming tonight
to tonight's literary
collaboration
between the Kennedy
Center and the Library
of Congress, La voz latina.
I do carry the international
festivals
with the Kennedy Center and we
just finished a major festival
on Cuba called Artes de Cuba:
From the Island to the World.
Literature has always
been important to me,
for all of the festivals,
and I'm so pleased
that tonight we begin an
addition to the Cuba festival
with writers from Cuba, but also
that we will have
other latino voices.
So From the Island to
the World comes alive
for me and for us tonight.
I'm thrilled that we are looking
at another aspect of the book,
the art of the book, with
the work of Rolando Estévez.
These handmade books
are so beautiful
and if you haven't had a
look at the books that are
in the other room,
please, do so.
The only time I've ever seen
such beautiful handmade books is
at the Booker Prize in London
that I go to every year,
every other year, and they
always present to the five --
the five finalists a
handmade book by an artist.
So, they are always
so beautiful.
I'd just never seen so many
beautiful books together.
There are only five there.
But I think that these
books, these book covers,
the books themselves, give us
another entry into the story
that will be told inside.
It invites us in a
very different way
than a book that's
printed by the printer.
And that's something that
I find very exciting.
It's another aspect of the art
that I think we should
pay attention to.
I'm so pleased that Ruth
Behar and Marie Arana thought
to have this as part
of this collaboration
and this literary event tonight.
I have to say that
this is the first time
that we've collaborated with
the Library of Congress,
the Kennedy Center, but this
is probably the fiftieth time
that I've collaborated
with Marie.
I have followed her wherever
she went, I met her probably
over 20 years ago, and she
is a writer extraordinaire
when she was the book
editor of The Post,
she did a fantastic job, and
here at the Library of Congress,
with the National Book
Fair it's extraordinary
that we see thousands and
thousands of people there.
No matter what the title of the
festival is, if I can find a way
to involve Marie in it, I
will, if only for advice,
but many of them have
included Latino artists
or African artists or
I've involved her sister,
I believe so, it's been a great
partnership and I love her,
she is a dear friend, I'm
so glad that she's been able
to put together this series
over the next few days.
So thank you, thank
you again for coming.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Marie Arana: Oh, my goodness,
I am glowing, thank
you very much.
Such a special friend,
absolutely.
Well, we have a very
exciting program for you
in store this evening.
The participants, as you can
see, have come from far and near
to tell you about a singular,
really truly singular art form
that fuses a love of
books with a love for art.
We are very, very
honored, deeply honored,
profoundly honored to present
Rolando Estévez, a poet, writer,
producer, and master bookmaker
whose handy work the Library
of Congress has been collecting
in its Rare Book Division
for many, many years.
Here to tell you
about that collection,
the Vigia Collection is my
colleague, Catalina Gómez,
who is sitting on
the extreme far end,
without whom this program
and the two other programs
that will take place
at the Kennedy Center would
not have been possible.
Thank you, Catalina.
Ruth will tell you more
about Rolando and Catalina,
but let me tell you a
little bit about Ruth.
Ruth, our moderator sitting
in the middle this evening is
a Cuban-American anthropologist
and writer, a professor
of cultural anthropology
at the University of Michigan,
her work straddles the worlds
of the academy and popular
books, she's written poetry,
memoirs, literary fiction,
books for children, she was born
in Habana and came to
live in the United States
when she was five years old.
Her family roots through
her grandparents, however,
go back to Turkey,
Poland, and Russia.
She learned very
early on in her life
that the world was
a very large place.
She credits her bookishness to
the fact that when she was nine,
going on ten, she spent an
entire year in a body cast,
at which point, Ruth,
I guess you learned how
to bring a large world
into a very small place.
In love with books, never
without one in her hand,
she studied Spanish
Literature at Wesleyan,
she learned her Doctor in
Anthropology from Princeton.
Her first book was based
on her dissertation
about a northern
village in Spain.
Her second book Translated
Woman was based on ten years
of field work in a
rural town in Mexico.
Her third The Vulnerable
Observer: Anthropology
that Breaks your
Heart, [ininteligible]
with a great title, exams
the role of the personal
in her scholarly discipline,
Cultural Anthropology.
Jewish Cuba is the topic of her
fourth An Island Called Home,
as well as her fifth
Traveling Heavy:
A Memoir in Between Journeys.
Most recently she's
published a prize-winning book
for young adults called Lucky
Broken Girl, and I guess that's
about the body cast,
I would guess,
and in fact it is, I've seen it.
It's lovely.
Congratulations.
Just this week she was named one
of America's great immigrants
by the Carnegie Foundation.
According to the Carnegie
citation she is "one
of America's naturalized
citizens who enriched the fabric
of our culture and
strengthened our democracy
through their lives, their
work, and their example."
We couldn't agree more.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Ruth Behar.
[ Aplausos ]
[ Ininteligible conversation ]
>> Ruth Behar: So I can
talk from right here.
>> Catalina Gómez: You
have your microphone.
>> Ruth Behar: 'Cause
I have my microphone.
Okay. Well, thank you so much.
I was not expecting that
introduction at all.
Thank you so much.
That was so beautiful,
and I am so honored.
Well, it's such a huge honor
to be here today at the Library
of Congress and also to
have this collaboration
with the Kennedy Center
and to be un conversation
with Catalina Gómez, from
the Library of Congress,
and my dear friend
Rolando Estévez.
So, it's really, really an
honor to be here today to talk
about a Cuban Love Affair,
the Art of the Book.
So, before I begin, I'm going
to just say a little bit more
about Rolando Estévez.
We've already covered
some of his bio,
but just to add a little
bit more that's important.
So, Rolando Estévez, and we --
in Cuba we call him Estévez.
Right? We don't call
him Rolando.
His sister calls him Rolly.
But in Cuba he's just known as
Estévez, people, a lot of artist
in Cuba go by their last name.
So, if you hear me
calling him Estévez,
I'm not being disrespectful.
That's the name that he uses.
So Estévez was born in Matanzas
in Cuba, and he is a poet,
he is a visual artist, he
works in multiple mediums,
including drawing, painting,
installation, performance,
and what's very important
to know is
that he also does set
design for the theater,
and that really informs
the way he constructs books
in a very theatrical
and dramatic way.
He teaches free style design and
theater design in Matanzas and,
in Matanzas, he is a leading
promoter and organizer
of artistic events, of
competitions, of exhibitions
and other alternative
cultural activities.
He really is a force
in Matanzas.
And in 1985, he and the poet
Alfredo Zaldívar founded
Ediciones Vigía, and all of you
I think had a chance to see some
of the Ediciones Vigía books
here, and it's very interesting
to understand how they
started out in 1985.
Initially, their aim was
to create a welcoming space
for young poets from
Matanzas, for local poets,
and what they did at
the very beginning was
to create beautiful
invitations to poetry readings.
That was basically
how they started,
and these readings
were always accompanied
by a musical recital.
So that was kind of the
origin of this project.
They didn't have paper.
This was the 80s.
They didn't have paper
to make the invitations.
So, they went to the local
butcher shops in Matanzas
and they asked for the brown
paper from the butcher shops.
And that was how they
started making these beautiful
invitations on very
simple brown paper,
and as you can see the brown
craft paper is still used
in Estévez's new books, which
I'll talk about in a moment.
So, Ediciones Vigía, important
to know that it was born
in the city of Matanzas, which
is 50 miles away from Habana,
and it's a city known
as "The Athens of Cuba",
because there's always been
a lot of reverence for poetry
and music in Matanzas, and it's
where the beautiful dance form
of the danzón was born
in the city of Matanzas.
And Matanzas has this historic
plaza, la Plaza de la Vigía,
and it was from that plaza,
which it translates roughly into
"the watchtower plaza".
It was from that plaza that they
could see the ships entering the
bay of Matanzas and they
could take action quickly
if pirates were trying to
come and take over the city.
So, this notion of
being a vigía,
of watching over
things was a definition
that was very important
to the co-founders
of this amazing book project.
And over time, Vigía
evolved, it grew bigger,
it grew into a publishing house
that involved writers, designers
and volunteers who
worked collaboratively
to create these beautiful
handmade books.
And the way it worked,
when Estévez was
with Ediciones Vigía is he
would make a complete book,
he would create, fabricar a
complete book, he would bring it
to Vigía, and then they
would make two hundred copies
of the book, and that was the
way they produced the books.
And what's interesting is they
gave attention to Cuban writers
on the island, and you saw some
of the books in the display,
like Dulce María Loynaz, Nancy
Morejón, Fina García Marruz,
Miguel Barnet, all very
important Cuban writers,
and always honoring José Martí,
the great independence leader
and poet of Cuba, but there was
also a commitment to give space
to international authors, such
as Borges or García Lorca,
as you saw in the exhibit,
Borís Pasternak as well,
while celebrating the work
of great American writers,
such as Emily Dickinson.
Y voy a hablar un
poquito del Dickinson.
So, I think all of you've got
to see the Emily Dickinson
book here in the display,
and it's just a totally
exquisite book from 1998,
and I think this is one of the
most spectacular handmade books
that I have seen,
and Estévez read
up on Emily Dickinson,
her biography.
He knew that she was
very agoraphobic,
and so he built a house for
her, for this reclusive poet,
and put the poems
inside that house.
At the time, Estévez had not
yet visited Dickenson's house
in Amherst, which
is now a museum,
but eventually he did get
to go there and he learned
that the house that
he had imagined
in his dreams had turned
out to be very much
like the one she had
inhabited in real life.
And so, the books
that he designed
for Ediciones Vigía are now
collected all over the world.
We have this wonderful
collection here in the Library
of Congress, there are also
books in MoMA, there are books
in the British Library and
I want to brag for a moment
and say there are books in
many university libraries,
including the University
of Michigan,
and we have a very large
collection of his books
in our Special Collections
Division, because the University
of Michigan was the
first American university
that Estévez visited,
when I invited him
back in the late 90s.
And, so, we began to celebrate
and to conserve these books.
So, between 1985 and 2013,
Estévez was the artistic
director of Ediciones Vigía,
and during that time he produced
over 500 gorgeous
handmade books.
And it's a major contribution
to Cuban art and letters.
We had an interdisciplinary
conference back in 2012,
called Cultural Bricolage,
organized by professor
Juanamaría Cordones-Cook,
and there was so much
interest in this conference
that we decided to produce an
anthology about Estévez's work
for Vigía and his
work as a book artist,
and I'm one of the coeditors of
this book which will be coming
out next year and
it will be called
or tentatively called Beautiful
Books in the Age of Technology:
Rolando Estévez and the
Making of Vigía in Cuba.
Today, Estévez will be
sharing his new work,
and this is taking him in
very, very exciting directions.
In 2013, he made the decision
to leave Ediciones Vigía
and form his own imprint,
and we saw there's a few
of the new books here.
His new imprint is
called El Fortín.
El Fortín means "the little
fort", and his plan was
to be able to produce
limited edition books as well
as one-of-a-kind arts books
and just to have more freedom
to do his work as a book artist.
An they've already gained
very, very wide recognition,
and with so - Me perdonas
si estoy hablando mucho.
>> Rolando Estévez:
No, no, para nada.
Por favor, no.
>> Ruth Behar: And
what's so amazing is
that Estévez is now the first
licensed independent bookmaker
in Cuba.
All right?
So, he's able to
produce these books
as an independent bookmaker
and he will be spearheading the
first ever artist-book pavilion
at the coming bienal, art bienal
that will take place
in April of 2018.
And a new generation of Cuban
book artists is now being born
and they are all looking
to him for inspiration.
So, as you'll see today,
his creative development
as a bookmaker has really
inspired him to keep pushing
at the limits of how to make a
book that can be called a work
of art and also be a
book at the same time.
And as his bookmaking has
developed, he's found new ways
for words and images to speak
to each other ever more
exuberantly, becoming, I think,
a modern version
of the illuminated
medieval manuscripts.
And I think in our
era of virtual books,
Estévez's work gives us all
the possibility of experiencing
that tactile sensuality of
interacting with books in ways
that restore to us the
wonder of the text.
So, to end these remarks, I
just want to say something
about my friendship
with Estévez.
We met back in 1994, que
nos conocimos en el '94,
so 24 years ago, we met
at the Habana book fair,
and Estévez had stepped
outside to smoke a cigarette
and to take a break from working
at the Ediciones Vigía stand
at the Habana book fair.
He was selling these postales
that were essentially these
beautiful hand-painted drawings
that incorporated lines of
poetry from Dulce María Loynaz.
At the time, I didn't know
who Dulce María Loynaz was.
She then became a huge influence
on my life, and he said to me,
"Don't tell me you've
never heard of Dulce María.
She's one of Cuba's
most important poets."
And I said that I
hadn't heard of her.
And I realized how
much I had yet to learn
from Rolando Estévez about Cuban
literature, culture and history.
And we struck up a
conversation back then in 1994.
He was watching me intently
and I ended up telling him
that I was this cubana who was
returning to the island looking
for my roots, I was
speaking to him of my need
to return even though my parents
didn't want me to travel to Cuba
and in fact they've
never been back,
and he nodded very
sympathetically and then he said
that I reminded him
of his younger sister.
She was an eight-year-old
girl when she left Cuba
with their parents in 1969.
He had not seen her
in all that time.
He'd not been able to leave
because he was 15 and considered
of military age by Cuban law.
So, he knew in his own flesh how
immigration could cut both ways,
producing grief for
those leaving as well
as for those waving goodbye.
And after our conversation,
Estévez said
that I should go
inside and have a look
at the Ediciones Vigía books,
and I said to him, "But,
how will I find them?"
And he said, "Oh,
you'll find them.
You won't be able to miss them."
And he lit up another
cigarette and I went inside,
and I walk through this
dark hall, seeing just a lot
of gloomy-looking books printed
by the government presses,
and I said, "Where do I
find Ediciones Vigía?"
And then I saw this tall
palm tree and it was made
of the brown butcher
paper, very tall palm tree,
the tree of course had been
designed and built by Estévez.
And he was right,
it was impossible
to miss these beautiful books.
They were all fashioned
from simple brown paper,
were handmade, hand-colored,
hand-printed, hand-bound,
and I didn't know what to
make of these creations,
but I fell in love
with them immediately.
And so began my Cuban love
affair with the artist
of the book and especially with
the art of Estévez's books.
So honored and so thrilled
to be here, and with that,
I don't know if I'll move
to Catalina Gómez o move
toward our conversation
with Rolando Estévez.
>> Catalina Gómez: I think
it should be Rolando Estévez.
>> Ruth Behar: Thank
you so much.
[risa]
[ Aplausos ]
>> Catalina Gómez: I
think you should --
I should be at the end.
>> Ruth Behar: You
should be at the end.
>> Catalina Gómez: I think, yes.
>> Ruth Gómez: Okay.
>> Catalina Gómez:
[ininteligible] the stars.
>> Ruth Behar: So, we'll
start with -- we're going --
we have several books
that we want to show you,
and discuss with you, and
I will be both interacting
and translating as
well from Spanish.
>> Rolando Estévez:
¿Quieres comentar alguno -- ?
>> Ruth Behar: Eh,
no, vamos a empezar.
Yo creo que yay o he
hablado demasiado.
>> Rolando Estévez: Ya.
>> Ruth Behar: Sí, sí.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Voy a empezar.
Bueno, quiero empezar mostrando,
darle las gracias a Ruth por --
y a la Biblioteca del
Congreso, sobre todo,
por esta oportunidad y por
cuánto me emociona ver esos
libros de Vigía y El Fortín
ahí, en esta exposición.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he wants to
say thank you so much to all
of us for being here,
the two of us,
and how incredibly moved
he is to see the books here
at the Library of Congress,
and so beautifully conserved.
>> Rolando Estévez: Quiero decir
primero que El Fortín es mi
continuación como artista
en el mundo del libro.
Empecé, fundé Vigía junto a
Alfredo Zaldívar en el '85.
Estuve 28 años y
más en ese lugar.
>> Ruth Behar: So, El Fortín
is a continuation of the work
that he began at
Ediciones Vigía.
He worked with Zaldívar,
the cofounder, for 28 years
and now is continuing
the work with El Fortín.
>> Rolando Estévez: El
Fortín es mi propio Proyecto.
Ya en Cuba puede haber un
proyecto privado de libros.
Fui el primero, ya lo dijiste.
>> Ruth Behar: Sí.
So, El Fortín, again,
is the first independent
bookmaking project.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Y este Fortín me da la
posibilidad de continuar mi
trabajo como diseñador
de libros,
añandiendo ahora el
trabajo de los libros arte,
los ejemplares únicos.
>> Ruth Behar: So, El Fortín
allows him to keep doing books
in small series while at
the same time being able
to make one-of-a-kind
unique artists' books.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Quiero empezar mostrándoles este
libro que es un poster de Alejo
Galván, un poeta de la ciudad.
Vamos a zafarlo aquí.
Estos libros llevan
una interacción.
>> Ruth Behar: His books require
quite a lot of interaction.
This is a book of poems,
three poems by Alejo Galván,
a poet from Matanzas, and it's
called La Tarde, The Afternoon.
>> Rolando Estévez: Se me hizo
un nudito aquí, momentico.
Ya.
>> Ruth Behar: Ya está.
>> Rolando Estévez: Este poster
contiene tres poemas de Alejo
Galván, poemas dedicados a
la ciudad de los puentes y
los ríos.
Aquí están las imágenes
de la ciudad.
>> Ruth Behar: So, these
are three poems that are all
about the city of Matanzas,
and Matanzas is a city
of three rivers, and the
ocean, and many bridges,
and so he captures
that in the artwork.
>> Rolando Estévez: En la cabeza
de esta mujer que es como la
ciudad, el lighthouse.
Me encanta la palabra en inglés.
El faro, que es el símbolo
de Ediciones El Fortín.
>> Ruth Behar: So, the
lighthouse is the symbol
of El Fortín, of his
imprint El Fortín.
And he mentioned that
there's a lighthouse coming
out of the head of the woman,
and he loves that
word in English.
So, he tends to say
"lighthouse" rather than "faro",
which is the word in Spanish.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Por la parte de atrás,
las informaciones sobre
la cantidad de ejemplares,
sobre el poeta, en fin.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he includes
information about the poet,
the number of copies
that were made.
So, all of that information is
always included in each book.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Pequeñas notas,
pequeñas sorpresas que
siempre tienen estos libros.
>> Ruth Behar: Notes and
surprises, as he said,
the books always
contain surprises.
>> Rolando Estévez:
En este caso,
una nota sobre el
poeta, sobre el autor.
>> Ruth Behar: So, there's a
note there about the author.
>> Rolando Estévez:
[ Inaudible ]
>> Ruth Behar: Entonces,
ese es un libro que es un
libro como poster, tú decías.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Como poster, sí.
>> Ruth Behar: Como poster.
So, it's like a book-poster.
Y la idea de poder también,
o sea, tenerlo en la pared,
como arte, como obre de arte.
>> Rolando Estévez: Sí, están
hechos exactamente para eso,
para poder leerlos, interactuar
con ellos o tenerlos en una
pared, como se pone un
cuadro, como se pone un cartel.
>> Ruth Behar: Ahá.
So, the idea of being able to
interact with the book, read it,
but you can also hang
it up and enjoy it
as a work of art as well.
>> Rolando Estévez: ¿Seguimos?
>> Ruth Behar: Seguimos, eh --
>> Rolando Estévez: Eliseo.
>> Ruth Behar: Eliseo.
>> Rolando Estévez: Este es un
poeta que no vive en la ciudad
de Matanzas.
Eh, este es un poeta que vive en
una pequeña ciudad del sur de la
provincial que se
llama Jovellanos,
un pueblo donde hay mucha
cultura negra, afrocubana,
un asentamiento muy grande de
esclavos hubo en ese lugar.
>> Ruth Behar: Déjame traducir.
>> Rolando Estévez: Sí.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this poet,
Eliseo Abreu Hernández is
from the province of Matanzas,
from the town of Jovellanos,
where there was and
continues to be a very,
very important Afro-Cuban
presence, culture and religious
and spiritual presence, and
that's where this poet is from.
>> Rolando Estévez: Este hombre
ganó el concurso Digdora Alonso,
que es un concurso de poesía
que tiene Ediciones El Fortín.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
he has a competition,
a poetry competition each year
at El Fortín and this poet won,
and therefore his book was
published in El Fortín.
>> Rolando Estévez: Es un
libro también bilingüe.
Casi todos los libros del
Fortín son o bilingües o
trilingües, porque es una
manera en que más personas
pueden llegar a leer el libro.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this book
is bilingual, and he tries
to have his El Fortín
books bilingual
and sometimes even trilingual,
so that more people can
have access to these texts.
>> Rolando Estévez: La bolsa es
como una pequeña mochila que se
pudiera llevar aquí al hombre.
>> Ruth Behar: [Risa] Probably
doesn't need translation,
but the idea that it's
almost a little knapsack
and you can carry it with you.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Este es un poeta fuerte,
enérgico, con poemas muy --
>> Ruth Behar: This is a
very, very strong poet.
Y este poeta está enfermo, ¿no?
>> Rolando Estévez: Está
enfermo, enfermo de cáncer.
>> Ruth Behar: He's
suffering from --
>> Rolando Estévez: Y toda
su poesía está llena de esa
imploración que hace a la vida
por que le siga dando salud y es
una poesía que también
habla del dolor físico y del
dolor espiritual.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he is a poet
who is suffering from cancer.
So, his poems have a lot to
do with physical suffering,
searching for healing, those
are themes in his work.
Seguimos.
La zafra.
>> Rolando Estévez: La Zafra.
Este es un libro que
me gusta especialmente.
Es un libro, La Zafra
de Agustín Acosta.
Agustín Acosta fue poeta
nacional en Cuba antes que
Nicolás Guillén.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this is
a book by Agustín Acosta.
This is a poet who lived
outside of Cuba, in Miami,
but before he left
Cuba, he was Cuba --
he was declared Cuba's National
Poet, before Nicolás Guillén.
>> Rolando Estévez: Pero hay
algo que es bien interesante.
Se fue de Cuba y perdió su
condición de poeta nacional y se
nombró a otro poeta nacional
en Cuba, estando vivo Agustín,
que fue Nicolás Guillén.
>> Ruth Behar: Right.
So, he was Cuba's Nactional
Poet, but after he left Cuba,
he was no longer Cuba's
National Poet, and that was
when Nicolás Guillén was named.
>> Rolando Estévez:
En los oscuros tiempos de los
'70 y las parametraciones,
este fue un poeta
prohibido en Cuba,
un poeta que había
abandonado el país.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this
is a poet that in the 70s,
which is a very dark period in
Cuban history, it was impossible
to read this poet's work.
>> Rolando Estévez: Escribió en
la década del 30 su gran libro,
La Zafra, y esta es
tapa la que contiene.
>> Ruth Behar: This is one
of his great books, La Zafra.
Is the sugar cane harvest.
>> Rolando Estévez: Algunos
de los poemas de ese libro
La Zafra.
Está realizada la cubierta
en caña de azúcar, prensada.
>> Ruth Behar: So the cover
has pressed sugar cane.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Fibras naturales.
>> Ruth Behar: Natural fibers.
>> Rolando Estévez: Para dar
toda la atmósfera del campo.
>> Ruth Behar: And this
is a selection of poems
from this book La Zafra,
The Sugar Cane Harvest.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y aquí
están los dibujos de la portada,
de la portadilla, está
muy lleno de dibujos.
>> Ruth Behar: So, it has a lot
of images, a lot of drawings.
>> Rolando Estévez: Cada poema
está precedido de un dibujo,
especialmente hecho para él.
>> Ruth Behar: So, each poem is
accompanied by an illustration.
>> Rolando Estévez: Hasta
llegar así al final del libro.
Y otra cosa interesante
es que la bolsa,
esta bolsa está hecha con los
sacos que se usan en Cuba para
exportar, para comercializar
el azúcar.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he used
for this book an actual
bag that's used --
these are the actual bags or
sacks that are used in Cuba
to transport sugar, so --
>> Rolando Estévez: Es una cosa
que he tenido siempre presente
en estos libros y
también en los únicos,
es que el material se tiene
que convertir en un contenido
del libro.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this has
always been very much the case
in his books, that the
container of the book has
to be part of the book as well.
>> Rolando Estévez: Mm-hm.
¿Seguimos?
>> Ruth Behar: Seguimos.
Una flor debajo de la bota.
>> Rolando Estévez: Este
es un pequeño libro mío,
una pequeña plaquette, un libro
con un poema llamado Una flor
debajo de la bota.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this is
a plaquette, a small book
with a poem that
Estévez himself wrote,
A Flower Beneath the Boot.
>> Rolando Estévez: Es un
poema en contra de la Guerra,
por supuesto.
>> Ruth Behar: It's
an antiwar poem.
>> Rolando Estévez: Que habla de
las botas militares que aplastan
los campos.
>> Ruth Estévez: That
talks about military boots
that squash the fields
and flower fields.
>> Rolando Estévez: Una sillita
que es como la espera de cuándo
van a pasar estos
tiempos de guerra.
>> Ruth Behar: This is a
chair indicating waiting
when these times of war
are going to pass and end.
>> Rolando Estévez: Aquí
hay una nota sobre el poeta.
Aquí está.
>> Ruth Behar: A little
note about the author
of the poem, there's the poem.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Un poema en español.
>> Ruth Behar: The
poem in Spanish.
Y está en inglés.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Y está por detrás --
>> Ruth Behar: And then
behind it is the English --
>> Rolando Estévez:
El poema en inglés.
>> Ruth Behar: The
English translation.
>> Rolando Estévez: Estas son
impresiones directas de una bota
military sobre el
papel floreado.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he
used an actual footprint
or imprint of a boot here.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Hecho directamente con
la bota de un hombre,
una impression directa.
>> Ruth Behar: Made
directly with a man's boot.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y
por detrás hay retazos de
uniformes militares.
>> Ruth Behar: And it's
got bits and pieces
of military uniforms here.
>> Rolando Estévez: Okay.
Este es el símbolo de
ediciones El Fortín,
es un cuño que tengo para estos
libros y siempre está en esta
página el cuño, el número
del ejemplar y la firma.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this is
a special stamp that it has,
again, symbolizing
the lighthouse,
is the symbol of El Fortín.
¿Seguimos?
Bolero [initeligible].
>> Rolando Estévez: Ah, Bueno.
Este es un libro muy especial
para mí, es de un gran amigo.
>> Ruth Behar: This is a
special book, this is of --
>> Rolando Estévez: Gran
músico, Lázaro Horta.
>> Ruth Baher: A friend of his,
Lázaro Horta, who is a musician.
>> Rolando Estévez: Vive en
Miami hace más de 20 años.
>> Ruth Baher: He's been living
in Miami for more than 20 years.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Ha ido constantemente a Matanzas
a cantar y pasó una cosa
muy curiosa.
Este año, al principio, fue y,
como no llevaba una
visa cultural,
no lo permitieron
cantar en Matanzas.
>> Ruth Baher: Ahá, wow.
So, he goes back, he's from
Matanzas as well, Lázaro Horta,
his friend, and he goes back
all the time to, you know,
to visit, to be there.
But this past year,
he went to Matanzas
and he didn't have
a cultural visa
and they didn't let him
sing in his hometown.
>> Rolando Estévez: Este
libro tiene cinco canciones de
Lázaro Horta.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this
book has five songs.
>> Rolando Estévez: La herradura
viene por el último poema,
la última canción que se llama
"¿Dónde están los caballos?"
>> Ruth Behar: And this
symbol here is for a poem,
one of the last poems, which
is about where are the horses.
>> Rolando Estévez: El
dibujo que se desplaza,
completamente todo
iluminado a mano.
Ahí no hay color
impreso en ninguno.
>> Ruth Baher: So that
lovely illustration.
Enséñalo otra vez.
That lovely illustration is
all hand-done and hand-painted.
>> Rolando Estévez: Esta piedra
es recogida en el barrio de
Pueblo Nuevo, el barrio donde
nació y creció Lázaro Horta.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
there's a stone there
from the neighborhood
of Pueblo Nuevo,
which is where Lázaro
Horta is from.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y todos
estos detalles se aclaran.
Siempre, en cada libro de El
Fortín, en el machón o colofón.
>> Ruth Behar: So, all of
these details about the book
and how it was [ininteligible].
>> Rolando Estévez:
Ahí se aclara todos esos
detalles de la Piedra,
la cantidad de ejemplares,
que la iluminación es
completamente manual, en fin.
>> Ruth Behar: All the
information, things like the use
of the stone, the way that
things were colored in,
all of that information is
at the end of the books.
So, the story of the book
is included with the book.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Distintos papeles,
distintos tipos de
letra, el piano presente,
que es el instrument que
lo acompaña en la música.
>> Ruth Behar: Different kinds
of paper, different kinds
of print, images, and then the
piano is there as a symbol,
since that is Lázaro's
instrument.
>> Rolando Estévez: Muchos
dibujos, la nota introductoria,
un bolero sin fin,
una ilustración,
un dibujo para cada
una de las canciones.
>> Ruth Behar: So, an
illustration for each song,
and "Bolero sin fin"
means "endless bolero",
a bolero that doesn't end.
Boleros are the beautiful love
songs that come [ininteligible].
>> Rolando Estévez: Cada una de
las canciones tiene también la
música manuscrita por el
músico, por Lázaro Horta,
y que después yo reproduje,
pero están manuscritas y
firmadas por el músico.
>> Ruth Behar: He also
included these manuscript copies
of the actual musical
notations of Lázaro.
>> Rolando Estévez: Así,
cada cancion tiene un dibujo que
está lleno de la atmósfera de
cada cancion, igual su música.
Y así, las cinco canciones.
Este es el marcador,
marca el libro.
>> Ruth Behar: So, the
five -- ¿Te ayudo?
>> Rolando Estévez: Sí, ábrelo.
>> Ruth Behar: The
five songs and then --
>> Rolando Estévez:
Este piano con alas.
Este piano con alas
que está aquí.
>> Ruth Behar: Ahá.
The piano with wings.
>> Rolando Estévez:
¿Dónde están los caballos?
La cancion que cierra
el libro, con su dibujo.
>> Ruth Behar: The closing
song is Where are the Horses?
>> Rolando Estévez: Y también
la música y después, bueno,
las informaciones que dan el
machón, el índice y todo esos --
>> Ruth Behar: And all the
information at the end, again,
about the book and how is made
and the elements that were used.
>> Rolando Estévez: Okay.
Seguimos.
>> Ruth Behar: Seguimos.
Okay. Los cinco poemas del mar.
>> Rolando Estévez: Cinco
poemas del mar y de la soledad.
A ver cómo pongo
esto para que --
>> Ruth Behar: ¿Te ayudo?
>> Rolando Estévez: Ya.
Cinco poemas del mar y de
la Soledad es otro de los
acercamientos que ha hecho
Ediciones El Fortín --
A la obra de Ruth Behar y a la
Amistad que nos une en el arte,
sobre todo, es una amistad que
tiene mucha entraña artística,
mucha entraña literaria
y plástica.
>> Ruth Behar: Ay, gracias.
So, this book is a
collaboration between us, again,
part of our long friendship and
interconnection of our lives
and artistic work as well.
>> Rolando Estévez:
También tiene una bosa.
>> Ruth Behar: It also
comes with a special bag.
>> Rolando Estévez: El libro
se llama Poemas del mar y de
la Soledad.
Tiene esta imagen de
la Virgen de Regla.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
it's called Five Poems
About the Sea and Solitude.
It has an image of
the Virgin of Regla.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Que sincretiza nuestras
religiones con Yemayá,
que es la dueña del
mar, la orisha del mar.
>> Ruth Behar: Which, the Virgin
of Regla syncretize with Yemayá,
who is de deity of the
ocean, of the sea, very,
very important in Cuba.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Tiene siete conchas.
El siete es el número de Yemayá.
El siete.
>> Ruth Behar: And she
has seven seashells,
because this is her number.
This is Yemaya's number.
>> Rolando Estévez: Cualquier
papel hermoso sirve para
trabajar en esta editorial.
Esto es unas servilletas
que encontré en una parte,
en un lugar del mundo y
me parecieron perfectas.
Se las pedí a la dueña, fui a
comer a una casa, y le dije:
"¿Tienes más servilletas
de esas?"
Me dijo: "Tengo una caja llena."
"Si me las da, me las llevo".
>> Ruth Behar: So, all paper
is beautiful for him to use
in his books and this particular
one, this paper that he loves
so much, he ate at
somebody's house and she,
this woman had these
beautiful napkins.
He said, "Do you have any more?"
And she said, "Yes,
I have a whole box."
[risa] And they ended
up in this book.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Hay un lenguaje del papel
en estos libros, ¿no?
El papel es el elemento por
antonomasia distintivo de
un libro.
Pero hay en estos libros
un elogio del papel,
una manera de hablar a través
de los papeles distintos,
de los distintos papeles,
las distintas texturas.
>> Ruth Behar: So, his
books have so much to do
with the language
of paper, with paper
and all its different textures
and in many ways the books are a
kind of praise for paper, right?
By definition, books
are made of paper.
Here, there's a kind
of reflection
and practice of the paper, so --
>> Rolando Estévez:
Papeles distintos,
aquí hay tres papeles distintos.
Están conversando
entre los tres.
Un papel albal, un papel
crepé, un papel blanco.
>> Ruth Behar: Different
papers kind of interacting
with each other, crepe
paper and other kinds
of paper coming together.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Como siempre,
los dibujos están muy también
aportando elementos de contenido
a estos libros.
Esta espada que tiene
el nombre de Behar.
>> Ruth Behar: Also, of course,
the images are very important
in interacting with the text,
and this is a sword,
it has my name on it.
He also added my second
last name, which you know
in Latin America
we use the patronym
and the matronym so much here.
So, in Cuba, I acquired
my other last name.
>> Rolando Estévez:
[Ininteligible] Este es un
libro bilingüe también,
están los cinco poemas en su
edición inglesa y en su versión
en castellano.
>> Ruth Behar: So, the five
poems, in English and Spanish.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Índice, machón.
Y aquí, entonces, el
número del ejemplar,
algo que es también muy bonito.
Estos libros no pasan
de los 50 ejemplares.
Están entre los 35, los 40,
los 50 ejemplares,
según sea el caso.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
each book is numbered.
This happened to be number 12.
And he makes these
small editions,
sometimes, 35, 50 at most.
So, these are small
edition books.
Eh, ahora este.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Ah, los judíos.
>> Ruth Behar: Los judíos.
>> Rolando Estévez: Ya.
Esta es una pequeña antología de
poesía judía, eh, que realizó,
es decir, al trabajo de
antologación lo hizo Ruth Behar.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this
is a collection of poets,
by Jewish-Cuban poets, something
that had never been done before,
that I put together and
it's called, in English,
it's I'm Loving you
from my Roots,
is the name of the collection.
>> Rolando Estévez: Después de
leerme la antología y un poco a
partir del conocimiento que
había tenido de la poesía
escrita por judíos en el mundo,
pues, entonces aquí salió --
>> Ruth Behar: So, after
reading these poems
and reading other
poems by Jewish poets,
Estévez himself wrote
a poem called --
>> Rolando Estévez: Un poema
que escribí a los poetas judíos.
>> Ruth Behar: Sort of his
response to these poems
that he wrote, called --
>> Rolando Estévez: Estos libros
también me están sirviendo ahora
en El Fortín para implicarme
más como escritor y como poeta
dentro de la dinámica
de los libros.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this is
helping him to really be --
to involve himself in
the dynamic of bookmaking
and of writing as well.
>> Rolando Estévez: Vamos
a abrir el libro ahora.
Zafando allí la rafia.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this
has some rafia fiber
to open and close the book.
>> Rolando Estévez:
El yute, la rafia,
el papel de corcho, aserrín.
>> Ruth Behar: Different
kinds of paper,
cork and other forms of paper.
>> Rolando Estévez: Cualquier
material es bueno para lograr
una imagen interesante en estos
libros, una textura interesante.
>> Ruth Behar: So, any
kind of papers is good
to create exciting
texture in these books.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Aquí está esta menora.
>> Ruth Behar: Here there's
an image of the menorah.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Con distintos argumentos
conceptuales,
que tienen que ver
con el mundo judío.
>> Ruth Behar: With different
concepts of Jewish thinking.
>> Rolando Estévez: El tipo de
letra es otra cosa que en estos
libros también tiene -- yo creo
que cada libro requiere de su
propia letra, su
propia tipografía.
>> Ruth Behar: So, each book
requires its own unique form
of lettering, of font,
and so he also works
on that very carefully.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Aquí está el prólogo.
>> Ruth Behar: The prologue.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y un
poco pensando en los judíos
fundamentalistas, se me ocurrió
la idea que el fondo del los
textos fuera negro.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
he also decided
to use a black foundation for
this book, thinking of kind of,
you know, orthodox people.
>> Rolando Estévez: Ahí
están los cuatro poetas.
Son cuatro, ¿verdad?
>> Ruth Behar: Son cuatro.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Cuatro poetas.
Están en español,
están en inglés.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
four poets in Spanish
and English are included
in this book.
>> Rolando Estévez: Aquí está
el dibujo que divide la parte
española de la parte -- la
parte en español de la parte
en inglés.
>> Ruth Behar: That
illustration divides the book
between English and Spanish.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Aquí, el otro.
Ahí termina, aquí empieza.
Y al final, bueno, el índice
y todas las informaciones que
llevan estos libros.
>> Ruth Behar: The index and all
the information about the book
and how is made and
the materials
that were used to make the book.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Después ordenamos.
>> Ruth Behar: Sí,
sí, sí, sí, sí.
>> Rolando Estévez: Vamos, así.
>> Ruth Behar: Vamos
a seguir con Frida.
>> Rolando Estévez: Frida.
Aquí está mi poema
a Frida Kahlo.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this
is a poem that he wrote
and dedicated to Frida Kahlo.
>> Rolando Estévez: Se llama
"Con duro polvo de óleo".
>> Ruth Behar: And it's
called "With Tough Oil Paint"
or Duro polvo de óleo.
>> Catalina Gómez: Golden dust?
No?
>> Ruth Behar: Is
it golden dust?
>> Catalina Gómez:
¿Polvo de oro?
>> Rolando Estévez:
Polvo de óleo.
>> Ruth Behar: Óleo, óleo.
>> Catalina Gómez:
Óleo, sorry.
That's right.
>> Ruth Behar: Yeh, yeah.
>> Catalina Gómez: Oil.
>> Ruth Behar: Oil.
So, Tough Oil Paint or
something like that.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Sobre el dibujo,
toda la iluminación de esa
cabeza fue hecha a mano,
los 50 ejemplares, uno a uno.
>> Ruth Behar: So, with
this book, all 50 copies,
these were all hand-illustrated.
>> Rolando Estévez:
La realización del
arete en forma de luna.
Un pincel, dos pinceles o tres
pinceles, según sea el caso.
>> Ruth Behar: We were
discussing this before
with cataloging, that at the
book fairy sometimes there's one
paintbrush, sometimes
two, and sometimes three.
So they're all a little
different from each other.
>> Rolando Estévez: Título.
>> Ruth Behar: The title.
>> Rolando Estévez: Autor.
El texto.
>> Ruth Behar: The text,
which is a beautiful poem
that he wrote and
dedicated to Frida Kahlo.
>> Rolando Estévez: Está largo.
Aquí el machón, con su sorpresa.
Estos libros siempre están
convocándonos a la sorpresa.
>> Ruth Behar: And then,
there's a surprise.
It's like the machon, the
information about the book.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y creo que
es una de las cosas que hace que
interactuemos con el libro,
es que lo podamos tocar,
podamos desplegar los
papeles que tiene,
podamos abrir este tipo
de informaciones también.
>> Ruth Behar: So, one of
the things that allows us
to interact with the book is the
way they are, these folded parts
of the book, and we can interact
with it and surprise ourselves
as we open and look
through the book.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y detrás,
el símbolo de El Fortín sobre
los ojos de Frida Kahlo.
>> Ruth Behar: The symbol
of El Fortín at the back
over Frida Kahlo's eyes.
Eh, Edith.
>> Rolando Estévez: Edith.
Esta es una -- la tercera
edición ya de este poema.
Es la primera vez que tiene
una edición de un libro
completamente hecho a mano.
La figura de Edith Piaf
está aquí, en la foto,
pegada sobre una concha marina
transparente, muy clarita.
Es una concha, es bueno tocarla.
Estos libros, yo sé que
no los dejan tocar mucho,
pero son muy buenos para tocar,
porque hay distintas texturas,
y aquí está el yute, aquí, la
concha marina, aquí, el algodón.
Se me olvida que tú
tienes que traducir.
>> Ruth Behar: No, no, sí.
So, this is a book
dedicated to Edith Piaf.
Again, it's a poem that Estévez
wrote and it's the third time
or third edition of this poem,
and it has a seashell there
on the cover with
her image over it,
and he says that
it's really nice
to touch it even though he
knows that we are not encouraged
to touch the books that much
at the Library of Congress,
but it feels very nice
to touch this cover.
>> Rolando Estévez: Aquí está.
Es como una carpeta.
Solo está agarrado
por este cordel.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this
is kind of like, like a --
almost like a portfolio
just held together with a -
with this bit of wool
or string in the center.
>> Rolando Estévez: Este es
un libro español-francés,
bilingüe.
>> Ruth Behar: This one is
Spanish-French bilingual.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Para homenajear a Edith
Piaf también con su idioma.
>> Ruth Behar: To
honor Edith Piaf --
>> Rolando Estévez:
Con su lengua madre.
>> Ruth Behar: With
her mother tongue.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y
entonces, aquí, está el poema.
En español.
>> Ruth Behar: Here's
the poem in Spanish.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Y también en francés.
>> Ruth Behar: And in French.
>> Catalina Gómez: So, wow.
>> Rolando Estévez: Ahora sí,
tenemos que doblarlo
para poder plegarlo.
Para poder seguir
hay que doblarlo.
>> Ruth Behar: [Risa] This book
has some complicated engineering
too, as you see, getting
them to fold properly.
>> Rolando Estévez: Yo creo que
es una manera distinta de mirar
al libro y vengo haciendo
esto hace más de 30 años ya.
>> Ruth Behar: It's another way
to look at the book or think
about books and he's been
doing this for over 30 years.
>> Rolando Estévez: Me da gusto
poder cada vez experimentar con
algo distinto, darle a
cada libro su carácter,
darle a cada libro su discurso.
Eso me da un reto, es un reto
para mí como artista tratar de
encontrar qué llevará
este libro, qué material,
qué dibujo, qué letra.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he really
takes joy in being able
to make these books and it's
a wonderful artistic challenge
each book, to figure out what
is this book going to need,
what kind of paper,
design, lettering
and to reconstruct
new books every time,
construct new books every time.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Entonces, aquí al final,
donde uno parece que
no va a ver nada más --
>> Ruth Behar: And here, when
you think there's nothing more
to discover, then you
come and now look at this.
>> Rolando Estévez: Aquí están
estos ángeles para Edith Piaf.
>> Ruth Behar: These are
angels for Edith Piaf.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Delante de la Torre Eiffel.
>> Ruth Behar: And in
front of the Eiffel Tower.
Yeah, ahá.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y al fondo,
el faro de El Fortín
convertido en la Torre Eiffel,
la Torre Eiffel convertida
en el faro de El Fortín.
>> Ruth Behar: And the
back cover, the lighthouse
of El Fortín transformed
into the Eiffel Tower.
Las damas cubanas.
>> Rolando Estévez: Yeah.
Un momentico.
Un traguito de agua.
Las damas cubanas es la primer
aantología que hizo Ediciones
El Fortín.
En este caso, hay
33 poetas cubanas.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this
is the first anthology
that El Fortín produced
of 33 Cuban women poets.
>> Rolando Estévez: Comenzamos
con Gertrudis Gómez de
Avellaneda y terminamos con una
mujer que ahora tiene 50 años,
que es Damaris Calderón.
No quisimos meternos en el mundo
de las nuevas y las novísimas,
sino llegar a ese
rango nada más.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
it's a book that begins
with Gertrudis Gómez
de Avellaneda, a very,
very important poet of
the colonial period,
and ends with a poet who's now
50 years old, Damaris Calderón.
Que ella vive en Chile, ¿no?
>> Rolando Estévez: En
Chile vive, en Chile.
>> Ruth Behar.
In Chile, lives in Chile.
>> Rolando Estévez: El juego
con la máscara es a partir de un
eslógan que tiene la antología
que dice que la poesía es una
máscara que el corazón se
pone para convertir el dolor
en belleza.
>> Ruth Behar: So, the use
of the mask is a very
important symbol in this book.
It comes from a line
that he quotes
at the very, very
end of the book.
¿Podría ver la frase otra vez?
>> Rolando Estévez: Sí.
>> Ruth Behar: The poetry --
>> Rolando Estévez:
Está al final.
>> Ruth Behar: Poetry
is a mask --
>> Rolando Estévez: Espera.
>> Ruth Behar: Ahí está.
>> Rolando Estévez: Aquí.
>> Ruth Behar: Ahá.
The poetry is a mask that
the heart wears in order
to transform pain into beauty.
>> Rolando Estévez: ¿Ya?
>> Ruth Behar: Mm-hm.
>> Rolando Estévez: Entonces,
están estas mascaras
en cerámica,
completamente hechas
especialmente para este
libro también.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
these ceramic masks
that were made specifically
for this book.
>> Rolando Estévez: Estos fondos
son retazos de unas sobrecamas
que me encontré en venta
muy baratas en Matanzas,
y las compramos y las
recortamos, todas las limpiamos.
>> Ruth Behar: So, the cover was
made from some old bed covers
that he found in Matanzas
and cut up and transformed
into this cover, this kind
of plush-looking
cover for the book.
>> Rolando Estévez: Esta
es la humedad que lo pega,
la humedad de Cuba.
>> Ruth Behar: That's
Cuban humidity [risa].
>> Rolando Estévez: Están
major aquí en las cajas,
que aquí las inventaron,
horizontales, aquí
están perfecto.
Yo, de verdad, realmente respeto
mucho estas colecciones de
Michigan, de Misuri, de
la Universidad de Miami,
la de la Biblioteca del
Congreso, que es fabulosa.
La conocí desde el
evento en Misuri,
que ella expuso el sistema
que encontraron para almacenar
estos libros.
Son libros frágiles, son
libros enemigos de la humedad.
Disculpa. I'm sorry,
>> Ruth Behar: So,
he's discussing how these
books are fragile and enemies
of humidity, and [fonética]
Gina Truise, at the conference
that we were at a few years ago,
discussed all the challenges
of conserving the books.
And he's so glad that the books
are being conserved in places
like the Library of Congress
and various universities,
and that they are, you know,
being maintained so beautifully,
'cause they are very, very
difficult to maintain.
They are produced in Cuba, but
difficult to maintain in Cuba
with all the humidity.
>> Rolando Estévez:
South California,
South California también
tiene una buena colección,
[initeligible] una que se
[ininteligible] en Miami,
pero ella dio una lección en
Misuri sobre cómo se almacenan
estos libros, que me
parece aquí perfecto.
Y uno siente una seguridad
muy grande de saber que hay
instituciones que los
tienen, porque son frágiles,
son delicados, tan hechos
con materiales reciclados.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he is so glad
that books are conserved
so wonderfully here.
He knows these are very
fragile books, they are made --
they are delicate books,
they are made with a lot
of recycled materials.
They are very, very
hard to conserve.
And so, he's so grateful
and so glad she did --
that you shared that
information,
and hopefully we'll
have time afterwards
to say a little bit
more about that too.
>> Rolando Estévez: Aquí
ya empieza la Avellaneda.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
that's the first poem.
>> Rolando Estévez: Pasamos
por todas las poetas, las 33.
>> Ruth Behar: The 33 poets.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Nancy Morejón.
>> Ruth Behar: Nancy
Morejón is here.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Sofía Estévez.
Toda una gran cantidad.
Lourdes González.
Muchas poetisas.
Este es su marcalibro, que es
una ramita solamente, como un --
>> Ruth Behar: So
that's a bookmark,
just a little twig for this one.
And --
>> Rolando Estévez: Aquí
está entonces el índice.
>> Ruth Behar: There's
the index.
Table of contents,
I guess we call it.
>> Rolando Estévez: Las 33.
>> Ruth Behar: The 33 poets,
and a lot of research.
When he did this I saw
him, when he was --
I saw him in Matanzas when
he was working on this book
and did a lot of
research into the history
of women's poetic
writing in Cuba.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Y el final del libro.
¿Ya no nos quedan?
>> Ruth Behar: Ya.
Ya estamos.
Ya.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Estamos para los únicos.
>> Ruth Behar: Estamos
para los únicos.
Sí.
>> Rolando Estévez:
¿Cuál empezamos?
>> Ruth Behar: Eh.
Aquí vamos.
Ponemos a Canción difícil
y ya los dos únicos.
>> Rolando Estévez: Ah,
falta Canción difícil.
>> Ruth Behar: Sí.
>> Rolando Estévez:
¿Dónde está?
>> Ruth Behar: Aquí.
[risa]
>> Rolando Estévez: Este es un
libro de una gran compositora
cubana, Marta Valdés,
una mujer del feelin.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this is a
very important book of the work
of Marta Valdés, whose is
an amazing singer, composer,
a very important person
in what was called
"the feelin" movement.
"Feelin", without
the "g" in Spanish.
>> Rolando Estévez: Es una mujer
muy afiliada a la ciudad de
Matanzas, aunque nació
y vive en la Habana.
Es muy afiliada a la ciudad de
Matanzas, le ha cantado mucho.
>> Ruth Behar: So, she's
a woman from Habana,
but she has spent a
lot of time in Matanzas
and has performed
frequently in Matanzas,
so she's very close to the city.
>> Rolando Estévez: Por eso,
esta bolsita tiene un poco
de arena del río San Juan.
>> Ruth Behar: This little
bag has a little bit of sand
from the San Juan river,
which runs through Matanzas.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y estas
cosas se convierten como en
resguardos para el
propio libro, ¿no?
De alguna manera, es eso.
>> Ruth Behar: These things kind
of become talismans
for the book.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Exacto, talismán, talismán.
Eso es.
>> Rolando Estévez: Hay una
coincidencia en la fecha.
Marta Valdés nació el mismo día
que Frida Kahlo, el 6 de julio.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
it's interesting.
Marta Valdés was
born on the same day
as Frida Kahlo, July, 6th.
>> Rolando Estévez: Pero también
la poeta cubana Carilda Oliver y
Marta Valdés también nacieron
el mismo día, el 6 de julio.
Aquí está con Carilda,
y aquí está con Frida.
Nuestra Marta Valdés.
>> Ruth Behar: Also, the poet
Carilda Oliver Labra was born
on July, 6th.
Same day, so she's there
with each of the two poets.
>> Rolando Estévez: Me
gusta indagar también,
me gusta indagar en el autor.
No solamente en su
obra, sino en su vida.
Por eso es que llevo
estos detalles,
porque me gusta indagar
en la vida del autor.
>> Ruth Behar: He likes to
explore the life of the author,
not just the work of the author.
So he tries to bring
those things together.
>> Rolando Estévez: Todas
las informaciones de portada,
portadilla.
Una nota que le escribe
a las canciones de Marta.
>> Ruth Behar: A note that he
wrote to Marta about her songs.
They are so beautiful.
If you haven't heard her, look
up the songs of Marta Valdés.
They are really just
-- very beautiful.
>> Rolando Estévez: Este
es un libro trilingüe,
español-francés-inglés.
>> Ruth Behar: It's trilingual,
Spanish, French and English.
>> Rolando Estévez: Primero
están las cinco canciones
en español.
>> Ruth Behar: There's
five songs in the book.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Después vienen en inglés.
Tiene -- cada sección tiene
este separador amarillo.
>> Ruth Behar: So, each section
has this image painted yellow.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Y, al final, entonces,
las canciones en francés, las
mismas canciones en francés.
>> Ruth Behar: At the
end, the songs in French.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Un dibujo largo.
>> Ruth Behar: And now a
beautiful illustration.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y
llegamos aquí al final.
Otra vez, manchón,
guardas y todo lo demás.
>> Ruth Behar: Bello.
Entonces ya [ininteligible]
>> Rolando Estévez: Paralelo
a este trabajo de los libros
seriados, es decir, a estos
libros que son originales
multiples, paralelo
a este trabajo.
>> Ruth Behar: So, parallel
to this work that he does,
which he considers to
be multiple originals,
so that's what we've been
looking at now, now he's going
to share these one-of-a-kind
books,
these unique artist's books.
>> Rolando Estévez: También
desde la década de los '80,
desde finales de los '80, vengo
realizando ejemplares únicos.
Un libro completamente
artístico,
con una sola copia, sin más.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
since the 80s,
he started producing these
again one-of-a-kind books
that have no further copies.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Venía preparado para
mostrarles tres voluminosos,
grandes libros únicos, pero nos
jugó una mala pasada la aduana
en Cuba y van a llegar
esta noche.
Así que van a llegar
después de la presentación.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
he shipped along
with his bags three big boxes
with spectacular new books
that he produced
specifically for this event,
but unfortunately, they were
held back at customs in Habana
and didn't make it
on his flight,
but they are arriving tonight,
and we hope to show
them on Saturday.
Very beautiful, ambitious,
gorgeous books.
So, we only have two of
these one-of-a-kind books
to show you today.
But these are quite spectacular
as well, and if you can come
on Saturday, you'll
see the brand-new ones
that he has just made, that
are really, really fantastic.
>> Rolando Estévez: Sobre
una caja de pinturas, ¿no?
Una caja de materiales
de trabajo.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this book
is made from a paint box.
¿Le cuento que yo
te la había regalado?
>> Rolando Estévez:
Sí, sí, claro.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
the story, briefly.
So, many, many years ago,
I gave him this wooden box
that was filled with paints and
brushes as a gift, and then,
years later, he gave it back
to me as this work of art.
[risa] And that's --
and it's called --
>> Rolando Estévez:
He devuelto el regalo.
>> Ruth Behar: He
returned it to me.
Pensando en mi amiga Ruth Behar.
Thinking about my
friend, Ruth Behar.
>> Rolando Estévez: Es un
poema del libro "La vena rota".
>> Ruth Behar: So, it's a poem
from a book, a beautiful book
that he wrote, called
"La vena rota."
"The Broken Vein".
>> Rolando Estévez: Entonces,
todos estos materiales,
que están ilustrando un
poco el poema que, a su vez,
se basa en un poema de Dulce
María que habla de cuando el
hombre se levanta el
abrigo, en el muelle frío.
Te acuerdas, ¿verdad?
>> Ruth Behar: Sí, me encanta.
So, this is a poem that
Estévez wrote for me,
but it references a poem
by Dulce María Loynaz
about the traveler, who's
lifting up his collar, you know,
to be met by somebody
at the port.
So, it references that --
the lines from that poem.
>> Rolando Estévez: A
veces, uno se pregunta,
¿dónde está el texto?
Porque si es un libro,
tiene que tener un texto.
>> Ruth Behar: Sometimes,
you ask yourself,
"Where's the text?"
If this is a book, it's got
to have the text somewhere.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Aquí, en esta cajita.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
in this little box.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Esta [initeligible]
>> Ruth Behar: Ups.
[risa]
>> Rolando Estévez: De acordeón.
>> Ruth Behar: This
is like an accordion.
>> Rolando Estévez: El texto.
>> Ruth Behar: There's the text.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y creo que
hay algo más, pero en el fondo.
Si mal no recuerdo, ¿o no?
>> Ruth Behar: Sí, sí, sí.
>> Rolando Estévez: Aquí hay
una foto de Dulce María Loynaz
porque, de alguna manera, es
la que nos unió en este poema,
donde estamos ella y estoy yo,
pero un poco a través de la
obra de Dulce María también.
Y por detrás, entonces,
dice -- habla de esta --
es una foto original que hizo
un fotógrafo de Matanzas a Dulce
María, y me la regaló, y
yo la añadí a este libro.
La quiero tanto que me
desprendí de la foto y se la di.
[ Risas ]
>> Ruth Behar: So, this
is an original photo
of Dulce María Loynaz,
de great Cuban poet
who won the Cervantes prize,
and it was a real photo
that he had gotten or that
a Matanzas' photographer has
taken, and he likes me so much
that he gave me this
photo that he had.
>> Rolando Estévez: Ya
no me acordaba de eso.
>> Ruth Behar: No.
He had forgotten about this.
And in a way, Dulce
María Loynaz,
like I said in my
introductory remark was kind
of like the bridge between
us, she was the first poet
that I learned about, Cuban poet
that I learned about from him,
and she really -- was
really important to me
and very important to Estévez,
and became kind of the bridge,
one of the bridges between us.
>> Rolando Estévez: Bueno,
entonces, para terminar,
vamos a hablar un poquito.
Con este iba a empezar yo la
presentación que iba a hacer,
pero la vida le hace
esas cosas a uno,
y es con el que voy a cerrar.
>> Ruth Behar: So, déjame decir.
So, he was going to begin, if
the other books had arrived
with his bags, he was going
to begin with this book,
and then end with the others,
but instead we're going
to end with this one.
>> Rolando Estévez: Bueno,
he hecho una larga colección de
ejemplares únicos de libros-arte
basados en los Versos
sencillos de José Martí,
que es un libro espléndido.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he's made
many unique one-of-a-kind
artist's books based on the work
of José Martí, particularly,
the "Simple Verses",
the "Versos sencillos".
>> Rolando Estévez: Y está
por todas partes Ediciones
El Fortín.
Bellamar es Matanzas, para
mí, Bellamar es Matanzas.
Yo le he cambiado el nombre
a esa ciudad porque tiene un
nombre horrendo y sanguinario.
Entonces, he empezado una
campana que a lo mejor florece
alguna vez.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he has
begun a campaign in the city
of Matanzas, because he doesn't
like the name of his city.
"Matanzas" literally means
"slaughter" or "killings",
so it's a very bloody name.
>> Rolando Estévez: Di lo
que quiere decir en inglés
"matanzas".
>> Ruth Behar: Sí,
sí, ya lo dije.
So, it's a name that he doesn't
like, a very violent name,
and so he's actually begun this
campaign to change the name
of the city to Bellamar,
which means "beautiful ocean."
So, he writes, as you
saw, he writes Bellamar,
that the books are made in
Bellamar rather than Matanzas.
>> Rolando Estévez: Es
un nombre más suave.
>> Ruth Behar: It's
a nicer, softer name.
>> Rolando Estévez: Ya.
Entonces, aquí adentro
está esta caja de yute.
Forrada de girasoles, que
son los girasoles de Ochun.
>> Ruth Behar: So, here's this
beautiful line with burlap,
and then at the top,
it has the sunflowers,
and the sunflowers are
the flowers for Ochun,
another important deity.
>> Rolando Estévez: Estos son
los restos de pintura que van
quedando en los platos, y
yo los aprovecho también,
que parecen como unas gotas.
Son restos de pintura,
de pigmento.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he has
leftover pigment and paint
that he uses also for the box.
>> Rolando Estévez: Este es
el poema uno de los versos
sencillos, una selección
del poema uno de los
versos sencillos.
>> Ruth Behar: This is poem
number one of the simple verses,
some fragments from it.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Aquí, entonces,
empiezo con un poco
de información.
Aquí hay papeles artesanales.
Aquí hay unos papeles que le
compré a una artista de papeles
en Michigan.
Es decir, el papel para mí
es una obsesión siempre.
Me gusta mucho experimentar
y combinarlos.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he says he's
very, very obsessed with paper.
This includes some paper
that he acquired while he
at Michigan, some
handmade papers.
>> Rolando Estévez: Vamos a
guardar esto para poder seguir.
Aquí está el texto del
poema, español-inglés,
gracias a un traductor
maravilloso cubano que vive en
Miami, que se llama Manuel
Tellechea y que tiene unas
traducciones espléndidas.
Todo el mundo habla muy
bien, yo no sé inglés,
pero todo el que lo sabe habla
muy bien de las traducciones de
Martí de Tellechea.
>> Ruth Behar: So, this
includes the poem in Spanish
and then translations
by Manuel Tellechea,
who is a Cuban-American poet
living in Miami, and he's able
to translate Martí
into rhymed English,
which is extremely
difficult to do.
>> Rolando Estévez: Aquí hay
cinco cuartetas del poema uno.
Cinco en español y las
mismas cinco en inglés.
>> Ruth Behar: So, five
stanzas from the poem
in Spanish, and then in English.
>> Rolando Estévez: Otra parte,
la ilustración de este hombre
ideal del que habla Martí en el
primer poema, que se
asombra ante la naturaleza.
>> Ruth Behar: So,
he made a drawing
that represents the unique
man that Martí refers
to in the opening
verses of the poem.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y
entonces, aquí, al fondo,
este pequeño Martí, José Martí.
>> Ruth Behar: Here's
a small Martí.
>> Rolando Estévez: El poeta.
Otra información sobre los
lugares donde estamos en
Matanzas, donde se nos puede
encontrar, está ahí también.
>> Ruth Behar: Some information
about where the book was made
in Matanzas or in
Bellamar, let's say.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y voy a
decir algo que he dicho muchas
veces, pero bueno,
aquí nunca lo he dicho,
es que hago muchas cosas
en esta vida artística.
>> Ruth Behar: So, he's
going to say something
that he has said many times,
but he has never said it here
about his artistic life.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Me he dedicado por muchos
años a la enseñanza del arte.
>> Ruth Behar: He spent
many years teaching art.
>> Rolando Estévez: Me dediqué
por más de 35 años al mundo del
diseño de escenografía y
vestuario y luces en el teatro.
>> Ruth Behar: For more than
35 years, he was involved
in theater set design,
and costume design,
and lighting design.
>> Rolando Estévez: Pinto,
dibujo, escribe poesía.
>> Ruth Behar: He paints,
he draws, he writes poems.
>> Rolando Estévez: Pero de
todas las cosas que hago,
lo que yo quiero hacer hasta
el día que me muera son
estos libros.
>> Ruth Behar: But of all
the things that he does,
what he wants to do until
the day he dies is this.
>> Rolando Estévez:
Estos libros.
Gracias.
>> Ruth Behar: These books.
Thank you.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Catalina Gómez: Okay, well.
[risa] It's very hard to follow
something so amazing like this.
I'll be brief because I
think we want to leave time
for some questions from
the audience, but anyway,
I'm just so humbled and thrilled
to be in the presence of Estévez
and Ruth, and such a pleasure.
Being a librarian and a
curator in the Hispanic Division
of the Library of Congress,
the division is in charge
of collecting materials from
Latin America, the Caribbean,
and Spain, and Portugal.
We're just so thrilled,
because we're just huge fans
of the Vigía, Ediciones
Vigía, and actually came
to know the collection
through Gina Truise who --
she works in preservation, and
they already mentioned her.
She has been involved with this
collection, did several trips
to Cuba before having her
job here at the library
and was extremely involved
with bringing, you know,
books to United States and also,
I think, she spent time there
and even worked with them.
But she did a great
presentation of the books,
and I remember how I was just
like, you know, in cloud nine.
It was just like a such
an amazing discovery,
and they just [ininteligible]
to everyone who's sees them,
because there's nothing
like them.
But they're just exquisite.
All I want to say is that
what also was beautiful
about these collections is just
to see sort of what can happen
in the library to make
these collections available
to the public, and again I am
here as a messanger because most
of this work was done by
other people in the library,
like Gina in preservation
building this amazinga boxes to,
you know, to try to preserve
this as long as we can.
They are made with all these
kinds of materials like,
you know, fluid materials,
tree bark and things
that [ininteigible] are
not the best for, you know,
posterity, I would say.
So, it's just amazing the
work that preservation does.
And in the display I think
you saw some of the boxes
that are made for --
to sort the Vigía books
and it's really amazing because
the actually build the boxes
depending on the shape of
the book, and it's amazing,
because they -- just, there's
so much time and love punt
into protecting them, and it's
just been wonderful to see that,
and -- So they are
acid-free boxes
that actually Gina would explain
to me that they actually buffer
and they actually
absorb all the acid
from the materials
so it lasts longer.
So that's -- it's
really neat to --
this is like a big operation
here at the Library of Congress,
and then Barbara Dash who is a
cataloger of this collection,
which has also been fascinating
to learn how someone spends
all this time describing
the material.
When people search for
these items in our catalog,
each book has a catalog worker,
and each book has a
very unique description.
And Barbara is -- does such an
amazing job, because it's to --
she describes all the details
that are in each edition,
and that is, you know, really,
you know, time-consuming work,
and -- So, we just love this
collection here at the library.
We wish we had more
opportunities like this one
to show it, because
[ininteligible]
that these books, you
know, are heading.
But, at daylight today it's
just great to have them here
and I just want to say that
we have close to 200 editions
at the library and it's
really, as Estévez said,
it's a beautiful collection and
I just wish we had more moments
like this where we can bring
them out, because it's just
such a -- it's such a beauty.
And this is one of many other
collections that the Library
of Congress has, you
know, artist's books.
So, there're many artit's books,
these are books that are again
like these works of art,
so they're like more,
they are more works of art
than, you know, than books,
but they are just these
incredible creations,
and these are all housed,
and the custodial division
is the rare book division,
so there're many sorts of
[ininteligible] involved
in sort of the operation.
And -- yeah, so many have
come through, you know,
people like Ge bringing them,
and now we have Luis Reta,
who is our vendor, who
buys material from Cuba
for the Library of Congress.
And, so, we hope we can continue
to amass this collection,
and now collecting El Fortín,
which is your new endeavor
and it's just so exciting to
be able to promote your work
and be able to ahow
it to the world.
So, with that I close
and I think if any
of you have any questions for
the artists, you know, we are --
I think we have a
microphone circulating.
>> Hi, and thak you,
Estévez, gracias.
Incredible, it's beautiful.
I've arounf three questions.
The glue, you know, is
there a special glue
that will stand for
20, 30 years?
And then one for
Gina, the archivist
or the preservation
person, would she have
to take photos of
every single page?
Because heaven forbid if
that glue comes loose.
And then my third or forth
question, and I think I sort
of know the answer
is, he answered it
in his closing comment,
like, this is his love,
and this is going to sound like
a jealous question, but, wow,
I would love to -- How do, you
know, does he interact like this
with the people he loves?
You know, a letter to
a friend, is that going
to have this loving, artistic --
like, when my mother writes
to me, she does similar things
to this, but -- so, those
are the three questions.
>> So, the glue or the
adhesive, there's a --
The adhesive is of a variety
and by keeping materials
in the closed boxes,
number one, in the dark,
and also in a controlled
environment,
we control the humidity
and the temperature,
the cooler the temperature, the
slower the chemical reaction,
and so the adhesive,
in fact, will work.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
So, the adhesive will be
preserved for a period of time.
One of the other things is when
various people go down to Cuba,
myself included, we take
good adhesive down assured.
So, I did that when I
went down in the 90s
and in the early 2000s, to take
adhesive down to enable them
to be able to make
more of the books.
So, I think that answers
both of the questions.
The first two.
>> [Ininteligible]
does he write?
>> But that's, that I leave.
[ Risas ]
>> Ruth Behar: Hizo una pregunta
con respecto más sobre el
pegamento y con el
modo de conservación.
Pero después hizo una pregunta
sobre el amor que tú tienes por
los libros y cómo tú muestras
este amor con tu familia o como
[ininteligible] una
pregunta más espiritual.
O sea, si quieres
decir algo más.
>> Rolando Estévez:
¿Exactamente?
>> Ruth Behar: So, you
want to know, we're trying
to truly unpack the question.
So, you wanted to connect the
love that he has for bookmaking
with other kinds of love.
>> Does he interact with
his family, friends,
in the same way he does his art?
It's apparent, when he -- when
you gave him the paint set,
many years he gave
it back as art.
I guess by -- it's kind
of a figurative question.
You know, does he interact a
hundred percent as the artist
with everyone he interacts with?
Like, he would have hundreds of
people wanting to be his friend.
They would be like,
"Write me a letter.
I love you.
This is art.
You know, just to touch
or be near is art."
>> Ruth Behar: Que si tú traes
todas estas formas con todos tus
amigos y seres queridos, porque
has hecho unos libros bellos,
por ejemplo, conmigo,
porque todo el mundo va
a querer ser tu amigo.
[ Risa ]
>> Rolando Estévez:
La cosa está en --
la expresión de un artista es --
o sea, tiene que
salir del interior.
Ahí nada más está todo.
Y cuando tú combinas lo que está
aquí en tu energía con lo que
está en tu cerebro y convocas
al acto intelectual y al acto
emocional, ahí ya todo se
hace -- se condensa, ¿no?
¿Entiendes?
>> Ruth Behar: Sí.
So, the energy has to come from
inside and that's always kind
of a combination of feelings,
and intellectual concepts,
and all of that kind
of gets condensed
into artistic expression.
>> Rolando Estévez: Y esto que
decía de la comunicación con los
autores, a veces, tiene que
ser hasta un poco espiritista,
porque hasta con los Muertos,
tú logras crear a través
de lo que han escrito,
lo que te han dicho,
saber de ellos,
yo me he preguntado
muchas veces:
"¿Le gustaría este
libro a Frida Kahlo?
¿Le gustaría?
¿Le hubiera gustado?
¿Le gustará?"
Si está en alguna parte.
>> Ruth Behar: So, it's a deep
communication with the person
that you are writing
about, the author of a text,
and it might be Frida Kahlo,
who is no longer alive
and he asks himself, "Would
Frida like this book?"
So, this kind of this very
deep communication that goes
on between himself as a
maker of artist's books
and then the author of the
work that he's writing about
and finding that kind of
deep level of communication.
Yeah.
>> Marie Arana: I want
to thank all of you
for this wonderful presentation,
but what a great review
to the artist's inspiration,
the love between friends,
the extraordinary
imagination that takes
to make these works of art.
We're very, very lucky to
have you, Rolando Estévez,
with us today, and Ruth, what a
marvelous interlocutory you are.
Thank you very much.
Catalina, we're so grateful
for keeping these books for us
and for future generations,
for posterity.
Thank you so much for coming.
And take another peek at
the books in the back.
Thank you very much again.
[ Aplausos ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.